[Music]
sorry universe head listen you didn't do
anything wrong
ever you have nothing to regret
you have nothing to second-guess do you
still miss Nick at all do you think
there's silly feelings there I mean we
did have a good connection I did miss
him a lot in the beginning I miss him as
a friend now he's just a really cool guy
I mean I can't say a bad word about him
so if you guys communicated at all
outside of like things for the show no
not really
do you miss him yeah I miss him as a
friend I mean romantically you know he's
I am not really sure if he is engaged or
whatever but he didn't move on from me
you know to get engaged to someone else
so you know my heart kind of you know
accepted that and I've moved on from
that but friend wise yeah like I'll
always be you know if he ever wants to
talk or anything hang out on when we
sound for that he's a great guy do you
think you were in love with Nick I did
love Nick and have you know I cared a
lot about him I don't know if I was in
love with Nick yet it was definitely
getting there but I'm glad he let me go
when he did then if you didn't see a
future with me which you know to me was
kind of surprising then he didn't take
me no fantasy suites with all of our you
know sexual attraction toward each other
what was he thinking
I loved your limo exit it was amazing
I'm done trying to impress
man
I'm going to be me and whatever happens
happens
but I will never kiss up to a man ever
again in my life what kind of response
have you gotten to that how people
reached out what a bit I mean women just
find it really empowering I always put
my man first and you know I just really
feel like women need to realize that
they should all also be put on a
pedestal is there anything that you
would change no no I mean I like to live
my life you know confident myself and
the decisions I make you know I learned
from my mistakes I didn't mean any harm
by it I didn't mean to offend anybody I
just could have gone about it in a
different way but you know when you're
trying to be like sexy and cute and it
doesn't come out right come on I mean
I'm only human I can't help if you know
it looked a certain way I tried
[Music]